Did I did retesting a few months ago and started some new supplements for anxiety and depression?
I really haven't noticed any huge difference in that matter.
I have a lot of supplements and it's very costly, so just to be on other supplements.
So I just want to be on the supplements that focus on cancer, what would be your recommendations.
Well, the supplements that I may have recommended if you asked me for some recommendations
for anxiety and depression, typically the first thing that I recommend is adaptogens.
So adaptogenic supplements can help balance your hormones, can help balance your adrenal
hormones, your pituitary hormones, your thyroid.
It can really help with anxiety and depression.
If those did not help, there's another cause.
So anxiety and depression can also be from excess glutamate in the brain.
So there's other things that you can focus on and those can be dietarily.
So make sure you're not getting exogenous glutamate.
It's in a lot of different foods, a lot of different processed foods, it's pretty hard
to go out to eat and get like a chidee or tie or something like that, that you're not
getting glutamates in it.
There's a lot of glutamates in a lot of different spices, a lot of different sauces, a lot
of different processed foods, and that will definitely increase anxiety, OCD issues and
increase depression.
There are some programs on your life for anxiety and depression, so that should be a go-to
thing as well.
Always with your life, you have a lot of programs on there for all sorts of different conditions.
Let that be your go-to for any other cold morbidities, other than your overnight programs for
your cancer.
For sure, use that as well.